[Música]
hola bienvenidos a migrantes el programa
semanal de france 24 sobre el éxodo los
saluda juliet riaño
[Música]
desde finales de febrero la mirada se ha
dirigido hacia ucrania los millones de
refugiados por la guerra un éxodo récord
que necesita especial atención sin
embargo en el mundo la guerra en ucrania
no es la única causa que obliga a muchos
a dejar sus hogares diferentes
conflictos prolongados en el tiempo han
provocado el desplazamiento fuera de las
fronteras de otros miles la mayoría
olvidados y en ocasiones invisibles en
sus comunidades de acogida en turquía
por ejemplo los afganos luchan por
sobrevivir veamos cuál es su situación
en el informe de nuestro corresponsal en
estambul adrià rocha
[Aplausos]
hoy es un día de suerte para javi
refugiado afgano asentado en turquía a
diferencia de otros días en cuanto
trabajo para una jornada donde ganará
nueve dólares
dinero insuficiente para vivir y ayudar
a su esposa e hijos aún atrapados en
afganistán
yo soy carpintero y en lo que más me
gusta trabajar es en carpintería pero
ahora como no hay más trabajo no hay
nada tengo que hacer lo que puedo y
consigo encontrar
javi es uno de los más de 4 millones de
refugiados que según la onu viven en
turquía llegó hace tres años huyendo de
los talibanes que la amenazaron por
haber trabajado para la misión española
en afganistán aún está a la espera de
que españa lo ayude as that man nada es
estable aquella no puedo contar con
quedarme en turquía porque en cualquier
momento si la policía me atrapa me puede
deportar de vuelta a afganistán por esto
no puedo seguir aquí ni puedo ver un
futuro para mí en este país
no la situación es similar para otros
refugiados hyatt como javi subsiste con
pequeños trabajos mal pagados debido al
alza del precio de los alimentos a causa
de la inflación sus hijos también se
vieron en la necesidad de traer dinero
al hogar
cuando vinimos aquí salvamos la vida de
nuestros hijos pero cuando veo cómo
estamos aquí así un día podíamos morir
todos ya está pero aquí cada día siento
que muero por ver a mi familia en esta
situación
la crisis económica que atraviesa
turquía afecta a todos pero no en
igualdad de condiciones para la
académicas ganan sahin los refugiados
llevan todo
en el mercado laboral los refugiados
trabajan en situaciones más precarias
hay una clara sobreexplotación una forma
de hiper precariedad y vulnerabilidad
ganan salarios mucho menores y la tasa
de desempleo entre ellos es muy alta
obviamente esos op
-hay pese a esta realidad javi no tiene
mejor opción y seguirá aceptando
trabajos precarios para sostener a su
familia
casi chico
a cenar
optarán para él y para muchos refugiados
turquía se ha convertido en una cárcel
de pobreza
en contraste los primeros esfuerzos por
atender a los refugiados ucranianos
parecen positivos los países de la unión
europea les abren las puertas una
acogida que se espera sea duradera en
francia- organizaciones trabajan en la
integración de los refugiados para
garantizarles un trabajo digno
en ucrania eran 200 gerentes o
administradores aquí en francia son
aprendices la guerra los obligó a
empezar de cero y ahora intentan seguir
los trazos sobre un papel con una
máquina de coser una oportunidad que les
permite ser productivos
es importante para mí ganar dinero y
hacer algo útil que ayude a las personas
simplemente hacer algo soy una persona
activa y es difícil para mí quedarme en
la cocina o simplemente caminar con mi
nieto quiero hacer algo más este es un
espacio de integración que busca
brindarle a los refugiados nuevas
oportunidades y capacitarlos para un
buen tránsito por el país
el objetivo y este es el interés en las
empresas de integración es ofrecer
puestos que sean accesibles de inmediato
ya sea que no hablen francés o que no
tengan las habilidades con nosotros
siempre habrá lugar la federación de
empresas de integración en francia
informó que ofrecerá hasta 10.000
puestos de trabajo a refugiados
ucranianos desde finales del próximo
julio y abrirles la posibilidad para que
se queden francés cac se trabaja mucho
en grados son francia es un país que me
gusta mucho y puede que me quede aquí
con gusto pero es muy problemático
integrarse en la sociedad sin saber el
idioma pero se espera que el idioma
tampoco sea un problema en parís esta
voluntaria dicta clases básicas del
idioma a sus nuevas alumnas que huyeron
cuando estalló la guerra en ucrania
estoy muy feliz de conocer a estas
mujeres ucranianas porque juntas podemos
ayudarnos a entender a la profesora y
también hablamos de todo lo que está
pasando en ucrania las hadas know crime
estas lecciones son impartidas gracias a
la iniciativa de la iglesia ortodoxa en
el distrito 20 de parís como iniciativa
para integrar a los recién llegados
el impacto de una guerra como la de
ucrania mantiene los esfuerzos en sus
consecuencias sin embargo en las
necesidades de un refugiado no hay
diferencia y durante años europa ha
cerrado sus fronteras usando a turquía
como un país que hace de muro de
contención para no recibirlos y el dato
de migración de la semana más de 115 mil
migrantes fueron interceptados en mexico
entre enero y abril de 2022 la mayoría
procedentes de honduras guatemala y cuba
15% de ellos eran menores de edad
hasta que inmigrantes de france 24 los
invitamos a comentar en nuestras redes
sociales con el hashtag migrantes f24
sigan con más información en france 24 y
france 24 puntocom
[Música]